he was one of the biggest r b music
artists of a generation now our kelly is
convicted of running a criminal
enterprise of sexually abusing boys
girls and women for two decades
his defense team dismayed despite weeks
of damning and disturbing testimony what
did he say what did mr kelly say to you
mr kanek
he is disappointed as i am
you didn't get to see what we saw in
terms of the discovery
you didn't get to see all the
inconsistencies
we said in our summation that the
government cherry picked their version
that they thought would support
the continuation of the narrative they
did traveling the world and winning
three grammy awards but a jury decided
this was also a front for grooming
beating and degrading young women for
his own sexual gratification
the attorney who represented many metoo
survivors says mr kelly is the worst
abuser of them all
i have been practicing law for 47 years
during this time
i have pursued many sexual predators
who have committed crimes against women
and children
of all the predators that i have pursued
however
mr kelly is the worst
kelly's relationship with another music
star leo was at the centre of this case
the prosecutions say r kelly bribed an
official to enable him to marry her when
she was just 15 believing she was
pregnant and he could force her into an
abortion
mr kelly now faces decades in prison the
music industry also stands accused of
turning a blind eye to allegations
against him for far too long martha
kellner sky news new york